[Music]
I'm here with my coworker Harry so my
name is Helen and we're both customers
and the customer engineers at Google
cloud so one of our jobs as customer
engineers is to assist our customers in
growing their application in Google
cloud so which tools and which services
will will fit their current solution so
during this session we want to do a
step-by-step walkthrough of how to grow
your application for one user all the
way up to a hundred million users and
why is the best design practice that we
often see so feel free to ask any
questions on the Dory Q&A Carrie and I
will answer the questions offline
afterwards so we're going to approach
this session the more customer focused
way so I'll be acting as a user of GCP
and Harry will be my customer in year
he'll give he'll be assisting me as I
grow my application so imagine I'm straw
I'm currently in the startup and I just
build my own e-commerce website and I
have you know handful of engineers
handful of employees in my company so my
first step in my cloud journey is to
deploy my application to Google cloud
platform and my first impression of
Google cloud is this I have a bunch of
services different types of services you
have compute or ajma'in learning and in
fact there is actually the more than
what's on this page right here so now my
concern is which service do I pick which
one would work for my current
architecture which one would I need to
consider as my application grow so the
second thing I looked up is design
architectures on Google cloud platform
and there are a few that I found online
some of them might be useful for my
architecture but not so much for the
other ones so how do I take the
individual services from a previous
slide and build my own solution
architecture that works for my current
solution right now and what what should
I consider as my
location grow so many of you might be
starting out in college just like I am
or many of you may have hundreds of
thousands or even millions of users on
your application so the takeaway is that
for all of you you should be able to
understand what kind of obstacles that
we will face and what is the best design
solution that we'll see
so let's break this session or my
journey into six stages starting with
one user on my app on my web app all the
way up to 100 million users and along
each stage harry obvious will be
assisting me to troubleshoot and
problem-solve
my current architecture issues so I'm
beginning my journey with just myself as
a developer recently you know start
created my e-commerce website and think
of this stage as the alpha stage
inviting my friends and customers to try
out my new website and everything works
on my development machine on my local
environment so the next thing I want to
do is to deploy my application in GCP so
think of it just replicating my local
environment into a VM in glocal platform
and one of the tools that really assists
me in their first few first phase of my
deployment is called shell so think of
it as a dedicated VM instance that is
installed with the older Google Cloud
SDK some frameworks some language
supports so this allows me to use
command line to manage all my services
in Google Cloud and even deploy and
develop my code and how shell so one way
that I often use it is if I have my code
in a repository or in the VM in TCP so
what I can do is I can clone that into
my cloud shell and edit it through the
built-in editor and then redeploy right
there in the cloud without using my
developer machine so the reason I use
this a lot is because I'm just starting
out my application after actor as a
developer you know IT ops
so as I'm heavily relying on cloud shell
to manage my cloud resource and conflict
in
first few stages of my application so
when I mean I want to deploy my
application in GCP what that really
means is I want to put my code and my
services in Google's infrastructure and
we have over 19 regions around the globe
and where we are right now we're
actually closest to a Los Angeles region
so I'm just starting out my application
and I want to deploy too much to region
closest to my customer Los Angeles but
of course as my application grows I have
customers all over the world so we'll be
deploying to multiple regions in the
near future so this is sort of a very
simple architecture that we currently
have now think of I deployed a VM
instance in u.s. West to the last Los
Angeles region and within that region
I've deployed my VM in zone a so with
the least amount of effort
I replicated my local environment to an
environment in the cloud it is currently
running a web server and a my sequel
database so the user can access this
solution through a domain name for
example my web app comm and the traffic
will be resolved at the external IP
attached to a VM so now that the user
can start you know test my application
test my alpha phase this is the simplest
solution on Google Cloud right now think
of it as the lift and shift migration so
now that we move into stage 2 and I have
around 10k users and I'm experiencing
some odd behavior and performance issues
so I can summarize that in three types
of issues the single one is single
instance failure so since I only have a
single VM and there might be a
difference different types of errors
that occur on that single instance think
of it
VM issues web service issues or there
are basic issues and whenever that
happens I need to either restart my
services reboot my VM what that really
means is there's there's downtime to my
whole application this is the cause of a
single instance failure so another type
of issue is a single zone failure so
imagine that
my VM is hosted in the zone a of Los
Andes region so for some unlikely reason
that something happens to that zone and
I don't have any backup instances in
another zone this will again cause my
whole application downtime and then
finally scalability issues
so as my allocation girls I have more
users constantly or concurrently
accessing my application which my might
cause some inconsistent behaviors and
that really can be avoided since I don't
have any monitoring or auto healing or
anything within my single VM right now
so based on these issues we can observe
my current architecture is really flawed
with single single point of failure
meaning one failure will cause my whole
application my whole system to go down
so based on all of that what I really
need is to build a scalable and
resilient weapon web application so by
scalable that simply means and my
application is to work with one user all
the way up to 100 million users and by
mozillian that means my application is
to be highly available it needs to
continue to function when an unexpected
failure happens and for example if the
VM hack is has issues or if there zone
is experience failure my application
needs to remain fault tolerance so Harry
is gonna give us some ideas of how to do
that in GCP ok thanks Helen
it's good to see your business growth
over 10,000 users this is the simple
architecture that Helen is running on
Google Cloud we start small and the
provision only one single bein instance
as the application grows the number of
the VN instance grows as well so we can
find it's getting difficult but still
manageable what if need to scale over
tens of VN instance and when one of them
goes down you have to take action or on
traffic dips you suddenly have all of
this server which are either so much
instance group counts
to come into the solution to assist with
auto scaling and auto held in instance
match instance group contains a single
base instance template when the service
needs to skill out for new instance
manage instance group can create a new
instance from this base template
in addition manage instance group has
three major features the first one
autoscaler autoscaler can create and
destroy avian instance based on the
loading which defined by yourself for
example you can use the network
throughput CPU usage memory usage as a
scale dimetric the second one is auto
Hildur other Hildur will recreate the
instance which become unhealthy and
healthy can be also defined by yourself
with the the cousin health may check the
third one regional distribution the
regional distribution you can distribute
all the be an instance across the
multiple zones which makes your solution
more highly available looking at these
three separate our features this
actually solve the previous issue that
we have scapulae t and high availability
with autoscaler we can make sure your
application is always scaling to the
current node with auto healer and modern
and regional distribution your
application can recreate unhealthy
instance and voice in goes on failure
now that we have managed instance group
configured we need to distribute your
traffic across all the VN instance
within the group this is where they were
load balancer comes into play using the
original manage instance group we can
deploy your instance across multiple
zones load balancer will spread the
traffic across always be an instance
within the group and there there is the
single and casa IP attached to this
neighbor load balancer so all your users
that were SS of this fixed any case
IP in order to assess a threat of
instance behind all this match instance
group now our service is scaleable able
to handle traffic and unexpected outage
but I'm sure many of you will wonder how
this stable service are scalable take
their base as an example in previous
architecture you can see that we run all
the service understand VN instance this
is half Rho scale in point of view and
also harmful to service availability
imagine that one instance down which
cost the entire service running on the
same instance down as well hence this is
the what architecture evolves we
decouple the application into the
typical three P three-tier web
applications the front end the back end
and their base they're managed instance
group is configured to both front end
and the back end service to provide
scalability and high availability at
each layer we deployed a VN instance
across the multiple zone to cope with
the single zone failure at FRA n we have
the cloud load balancer to distribute
the traffic to the FRA end and we use
the internal load balancer to spread
their traffic to the back-end service as
we deploy our back-end service into the
private network and the therapist layer
my sequel is running on compute engine
with the hie mode this provides the
master to slave replication for each a
purpose and you can read Rebecca can be
added manually to improve the
performance and don't forget the
monitoring and logging which easily
helps you to trouble you your system
when something goes wrong state driver
is a comprehensive service that helps
you monitor and make alert policy in
abnormal situation if you have auditing
or troubleshooting needs the state
driver log in and the tracing abilities
are exactly for that
in addition state driver debugger can
help you debug your
your service online without interrupting
your service so in this stage we address
scalability and the resilience through
the manager instance group and load
balancer application is also decouple
into three tiers to avoid interruption
between services state driver is a
comprehensive service to help you
monitor debug.trace your system so hope
that is helpful to design your system at
least phase Helen thanks Harry so now
that we have the common three tier
application my user has grown to 100k
and we actually run into a new issue so
looking back at the current design that
we have everything is scalable highly
resilient so going to 100k has has
created a new issue in my architecture
specifically the data layer so since my
sequel database right now is installed
and I had to manually manage it on VMs
in the compute engine so this is not a
very scalable solution so as the number
of user grow number of concurrent user
growth at a same time so number of
concurrent read and writes to my VMs
will increase and this is going to cause
some issues on my Dera later there are a
couple ways to improve this so one of it
is maybe I can increase the disk on my
current VM which will increase the ops
or another way is I can add another
replica that Harry mentioned but this is
all overhead we have to install mainly
installed VMs manage the VMs manager C
code there are bases so I want to take
it as a cloud approach so I can manage I
can maybe leverage cool clouds manage
sequel services or another way is if I
can offload my database loading using
Redis cash so back to the database issue
there are many database services on
Google cloud platform right now and I'm
not really sure which one should I pick
which one will be useful for my current
situation Harry what do you think okay
yeah so choose Thea base and the storage
is one of the most critical mission when
you
belong your service on Google cloud
there are many services the storage and
they are based services you can adapt
based on your use case and the scenario
take their base as a eastern hope you
have choice on relational database no
secure database and they are wheelhouse
as well if you have the typical
transaction to process the relational
database will be the good choice for you
here in our case we were focusing in
memory database and the relational
database as we need early stage look at
the current solution that we are running
my Seco on compute engine it has few
areas that we can improve we know that
their base engine is the fast involving
technology so the new major version and
the minor patched version keeps coming
to enforce the database a demonstrator
upgrading the software as user growth
the disk of your database grows as well
there's no easy way for you to extend
your disk space for your database and
there is no manage the rear abaca for
you at the database layer in previous
architecture to separate the read and
write operation for your for your
database this separation can also can
also reduce the overhead of the master
database so with the managed service
clásico it helps you smoothly upgrade
your database in the maintenance window
that you specified what when you need to
extend your or their base disk clásico
can increase your disk when your disk is
running out and this disk increase
Magnusson it doesn't affect you don't
affect your database or you you don't
need to stop your database service you
can just increase on the fly and also
clásico can automatically increase your
disk when your disk this space is
running out and you can also define the
threshold that you want to increase or
trigger this automatic disk space in
mechanism clásico also provides the fail
over Rebecca and Rebecca to help you
easily scale your database so fell over
Rebecca gives you both the ability and
also high availability this serves your
money without provision or standby
instance not being able to read and last
but not least the clásico periodically
create a snapshot of your database so
you can restore your database from this
managed Big Ups let's quickly look at
how fill / works in this diagram you can
see that the primary instance can be SS
we are IP address Y and we have the
field over Rebecca which can also be
read B is IP address Z and we provision
additional one Rebecca to you for a
really workload and it can be assessed
via IP address X so every second the
primary instance will send a harpy
signal if the multiple harvest signal
are not detected the field over
mechanism is initiated the field over
Magnussen will be also are triggered
when the primary zone from the primary
zone experience failure when the failure
when a fare over is initiated clásico
waits for the fail over Rebecca to catch
up to the primary instance States the
amount of the time this state text is
highly affected by the replication lag
so here is the final state after the
fair over the field over Rebecca is
promoted to the primary instance row the
primary instance name and IP address
moved to the oil field over Rebecca so
the client application reckon X to the
primary instance without changing its
original database connection stream
because the primary instance IP address
move automatically to the old fair over
Rebecca
so another point that he'll mention
Alpini of this stage is to use cash to
route the re and right traffic from
their base to the cache memory store for
ladies is used to handle fast read and
write operations
you can keep your frequent SS data in
the cache like the frequent SS data like
the session info we can keep this
session involved in the cache in order
for your application to access this
frequent SS information quickly in
previous in it also provides the low
latency for application to access this
frequent SS data
he also significantly of though that
they are based loading from your
database memory so for Redis also gives
you the ability to increase your memory
on the fly without stopping your cache
services of course you also provide a
standby mode to provide a high
availability when the primary instance
is done on a song failure here we add
two type of database into the solution
we adapt the fully manage relational
database service
Cousy grow to easily create the fill
over Rebecca and Rebecca manage memory
store for Redis is also added between
the Beggan and their base there in order
to you of know that they are based
loaded and provide the load latency for
application to SS those frequent SS data
the design Ashley stage we focus on the
service is ability to for your
application instead of managing your
servers night right now we address to
their base issue the sky bility and the
high availability with cows ego and the
memory store back to you Helen
Thank You Harry
so with you leveraging out their manage
databases our application is now more
stable and we got to a hundred sorry 1
million users so my e-commerce website
is getting very popular and the next
stage we're dealing with another type of
issue
sorry so looking at my current
architecture right now I'm serving my
app I'm serving my users globally now I
have 1 million users so my users are
coming from Europe Asia so my next step
is to create a global faster web app so
looking at the current architecture you
can see that everything is hosted in the
u.s. West 2 region meaning that it's not
really effectively serving my customers
globally so my next step is to replica
replicate this environment into another
region for example u.s. East so I did a
little research and this is a common
approach that I see so I had my
architecture my solution on the u.s.
West region and I did a replica in u.s.
East and I used the DNS policy to split
the traffic evenly but for some reason
what if I wanted to add new VMs in my US
East region what I need to do here is I
need to update my DNS policies but that
my another issue might occur is with DNS
cache by the client so what I do here is
I can set a lower TTL value to mitigate
this issues but what if some of IBM's is
experiencing outages how're my DNS
policies adapt to that and if I'm adding
another region to my solution for
example in Europe I want to use DNS
geolocation routing instead meaning that
users from Europe will be routed to
Europe region users from US quest will
be routed to the u.s. quest region but
as you can see whenever I need to add a
new region to my solution or I need to
add or edit the loading
I'm an architecture or my solution I
have to do a lot of updates to my DNS
policies so I'm wondering if there's a
better way to do this in Google cloud
platform okay
so Wow expanding the business globally
is really exciting but it also comes
with some difficulties that you want to
manage your service across multiple
region so Google cloud go below balancer
is built on top of the Google global
network to spray the traffic of your
user across multiple region you can
configure a single and Castle IP or call
virtual IP the veep on global load
balancer without creating multiple load
balancer IP for each region this means
that you don't need to manage your DNS
policy the DNS resolution always point
to the single and cache IP address so
when you when your ecommerce business is
getting popular in Singapore for example
you continue to expand your service in
Singapore region so without changing
your DNS policy without requiring
additional with IP address in new region
just one single whip across let go you
can add your new services in Singapore
region into this global load balancing
service along with the single IP global
reach you can also get the crossed
region fail over and spill over
mechanism on the global load balancer
for example in real case if you have all
your instance in the Singapore region
goes down user in Singapore will
continue to be served by being redirect
to the application back-end in other
region similarly if your application
begins in the u.s. west are overloaded
the users traffic will be smoothly
handled by the application package
service in u.s. East so the global load
balancer help you to rebalance your
traffic and
so you were available resource capacity
in multiple region dynamic dynamically
along with the global load balancer you
can also enable the cloud Sirian to a
server your content delivery to your
end-user
user experience can be improved because
your content will be cached in the local
pub and served to the local user it
significantly shorten the response time
to your user and also your static
content can stored in the Google Cloud
storage who will call storage and this
static content can be served at the CDN
local pub for those come dynamic or
static content generated by your server
Google Cloud CDN can reduce the service
loading to avoid sending every request
back to your back-end service now that
we can serve user request with the
global load balancer but can we make our
relational database accessible across
multiple region another issue is most
most database today require making
trade-off between sky bility and the
consistency so good class banner you get
the best of the relation of their base
structure and also non-relational of
their base skill with strong consistency
across rows regions and the countenance
class banner has regional deployment and
multi-region deployment with
multi-region deployment it automatically
sync your data across multiple region so
that your your service in each region
can assess the local consistent data you
can skill out spanner capacity by adding
additional or instance on the fly
without stopping spanner service ok so
finally this is our architecture to
deploy your service into multiple region
to serve global users global load
balancer has a single IP for user
without manage your our DNS policy it's
cross region spillover and failover
mechanism dynamically dispute your user
request to multiple region when your
capacity in each region changes along
with Klaus ideon you route your users to
the closest pop to accelerate your
contents delivery and cloud spanner
gives you a relational database with
global consistency and thus capability
we list our global service expanding
your global business it's not difficult
anymore
Thank You Harry well now we are serving
our customers globally and we have up to
10 million users now so if we go back
everything started with a small start
start up one developer one VM and now we
have 10 million users so definitely we
have a lot more than just one developer
so now that we we are having different
cuts different developers different
teams I t's and Men ops and we're
constantly updating our code we're
constantly deploying our updates which
is getting harder to manage with the new
teams and many people working on the
same projects many developer working on
the same projects so my next step that I
want to do for my company is to shift
from from a monolithic architecture to a
microservices architecture so the idea
that I have is to split engineers by
microservices so imagine that I have
five to ten engineers just working on
the recommendation engine another five
to ten junior is working on the back-end
or another for front-end so this will
allow engineers with similar technical
skills and experiences to work in the
same team but the end goal is to improve
my development cycle and make it easier
to manage each services so think of this
think of this architecture as a
conventional to eat your application you
have that database back-end front-end so
how do I compose this to a microservices
architecture so I can decompose this
with looking
there were applications services
functions so for example I can have a
micro service for authentication and
that microfiber is micro service for
front-end
another for back-end so we can kind of
see how my architecture will look like
if it's micro service architecture but
how do we manage this in Google cloud
platform how do we manage the amount of
services and to manage all the growth of
micro services so welcome to the micro
services and the container war Helen
okay so it's great to see your team
expand to the multiple functional team
and also reconsider to redeploy or
redesign your service to run and manage
containerized micro services there are a
few things we need to think about a
container like the extraction platform
which can help you focus on your
application development deployment not
the infrastructure management for
example this includes some be an
instance auto scaling cluster management
or your container service scaling it
should be also easy for your team to get
started with and also easy for how to
integrate with your existing sea sed
pipeline so google kubernetes engine gke
fits almost everything you need here gke
is a managed kubernetes service on
google cloud so it provides the
fundamental features to help you manage
and deploy your can't analyze the
service for example for the auto skill
cluster auto scaling it manage your
cluster master know and you will work a
note and you can scale based on you will
worker node loading and also it has a
horizontal part of the scaling to scale
your path service based on the metric
you define and also to protect your
kubernetes cluster it provides the
role-based access control the private
cluster naval policy different security
features to fortify your cluster so not
only fundamental feature it also has
some advanced feature too
your service the last type the multi
crosser ingress as an example since
european-based our service is already
deployed across multiple region so you
want to deploy your account analyze the
micro service across multiple region as
well for micro service will you will
need to deploy your agrinext cluster in
each region and want to manage this
cluster service as a whole to serve your
global user so logically Motty cluster
ingress or features is the advanced
service that can achieve this goal in
this diagram you can find the web
application service is deployed into two
cluster which are running in two
different regions which we carry
multicast e ingress it distributed the
users request to listen to a different
kubernetes cluster in different region
based on the containers availability and
capacity so it has the similar concept
to the global load balancer we can based
on your past service or container
service of availability and also the
capacity to dynamically adjust the
request to different region and in
addition to the container extraction
platform the CSC de Arce over-deliver
pipeline is also important for your
development in and operation team to
stimulus to seamlessly collaborate
together on Google cloud the cloud
source repository offers a managed
source control repository service which
can trigger the club you to build a new
revision based on the criteria you
define for example if you push the cope
with a new revision and it has the
specific tag then you want to trigger
some build to you to build a new
revision
locks one example and you can register
your container in the cloud register and
integrate with the spinning spinning her
for continuous deployment when a
container of the new revision is
available in the car register you can
trigger a new spinnaker deployment
pipeline and this deployment pipeline
can deploy your service into the App
Engine the gke or even the compute
engine an absurd appointment you can use
the state driver to monitor your
deployment status and also service
status this completes full cycle of the
software or delivery of tcp and it could
also be possible that you're developing
or operation team already has their
existing solution in the CI CD pipeline
so one of the unique value on TCP and
the GK as well is openness so Google are
open source many Google Google service
like the tensorflow like kubernetes
Apache beam
therefore our managed service are also
open that you are smoothly integrate
with this open source project in this
target you can see that at each stage of
the deliver pipeline you can use the
different different open source projects
to integrate with the Google managed
service this gives you the flexibility
to create your own CI CD pipeline so the
architecture evolves as this high level
architect architecture diagram shows the
gke now is managing is managing all the
containerized micro services and we
create a CI CD pipeline to manage
application development deployment and
operation list development team can use
this C sed pipeline to push their code
and build a new revision package
operation team can deploy a new revision
into the staging or the production
environment and use the different tools
to monitor your deployment and service
status so Helen I think this
architecture are can help you to manage
your can terrorize micro services in the
CSE deep I plan to see
Thank You Harry so we're at the last
stage we have 100 million users now so
in this section we're actually just
going to discuss something that we
haven't talked about yet data or in our
case big data so imagine that we have
100 million users on my application now
and there are a lot of data to be
captured so for this section I want to
see what kind of services in Google
Cloud can help me with that so let's
start to think about what kind of data
can be captured on an e-commerce website
from the front end or UI perspective I
can have click stream or user view
history how long a users stay on each
page on the back inside I can look at
items added to a shopping cart or the
order history but all the data are
collected what I really want is to
understand my users and get the business
insights so I can answer questions such
as I want to create a better
recommendation engine or I want to
understand my user and do a user
segmentation so looking back on the data
I can actually categorize them in two
types streaming and bash data streaming
or the streaming data are other types
like click stream that's coming in now
real-time and I'm for batch data I think
of it as logs or database database data
so at all that a lot of these data are
actually captured a very large scale I'm
I'm not really sure how to do this on
Google cloud what kind of services would
helping with that
ok so 100 million users that is amazing
so with the hundred million users you
can imagine how large they are violent
you need to ingest and the process so
imagine each click and the view history
are the streaming data generated by your
user action and also no matter he or she
visit your website click some popular
item then you will be generate one
streaming data so no need to mention
that how this huge data volume will be
generated unlike the Blood Black Friday
or Cyber Monday so for such tremendous
data you need to ingest the Google cloud
pops up service could be your best
choice cloud pub/sub service can scale
out automatically based on your ingest
data ballin and also it guaranteed and
this one's deliver for your subscriber -
for your further processing afterwards
and for batch data you can already store
your SS lock in the Google Cloud storage
and some translational data it can store
in the relational database like clásico
or spanner
so after ingest the streaming data the
cloud dataflow can help you pre
processing your data before you store
its data into your data warehouse for
example you may want to remove some
duplicate data formalize or normalize
your data set and afterwards you will
store all these normalized data in the
day away
they are warehouse like the like
bigquery and once you streaming your
data and also data are ingest
pre-processed and the store or your data
into the data analytic service like
bigquery you also have other data you
want to aggregate or consolidate into
their warehouse for example you may have
the your CRM your customer profile your
purchase history and you invent
inventory information all this data you
want to be consulted them into the
bigquery there were Health Service and
afterwards you can consider to leverage
the Google cloud a I service for example
you may use the cloud machine learning
engine to blow up your own machine any
model to forecast the demand or also
build a recommendation engine on the
tensorflow model to recommend some
popular items or used or to build a
personalized recommendation engine for
your users
so this is the final architecture to
incorporate the data injection and the
process pipeline cloud pub/sub in
gesture streaming data from different
source like the web server or from your
SS log in both streaming data and the
best data can be pre processed by the
data flow and aggregate into that they
always have their warehouse service
bakery in your taya scientists and
business analysts can use a whole list
view of your data to attract your
customers inside from bigquery so Helen
would you like to conclude our journey
from one user 200 million users that was
a this is a very I think very exciting
architectures starting with our single
VM all the way up to this solution
architecture so looking back on our six
stages we started with a small startup
just alpha phase all the way up to one
hundred million users so at stage two we
want we decoupled our application we
made our application scalable and
resilient and at stage three we
leveraged manage database services like
cloud seco and memory store to have a
better and stable dare layer and stash
Stage four we wanted to move our
regional service into a global service
global load balancers Citians cloud
spanners helped me to deploy my
application globally and as stage 5 we
changed the way our developers work
our engineers work we move from a
monolithic architecture into a micro
services architecture and we added the
CIT D practice into our architecture so
finally stage 6 where we started to
collect our user data with the end goal
of understanding our user behavior and
our business insights but I don't want
to think of stage 6 as the end of a
culture knee instead it is actually the
beginning of a data journey and again
I'm lost
I'm not sure where to start on my data
journeys
Harry please help me okay so it's
exciting to discuss the next journey the
data journey on Google cow but
unfortunately we will need another
session to discuss it so don't worry
this is the last line of lease
regulation so back to our cloud journey
it's more like rocket science that at
each day at each stage it has its way to
fail or difficulties we need to cope
with so scapular the issue high
availability issues get security and etc
so at each stage we have shown a
different approaches to cope with these
difficulties and this is our cloud
journey 200 million users
it's a tough journey to get through so I
hope this journey is helpful for you to
get ready and lunch you will call rocket
engine so thanks for attending this
breakout session it's a pleasure to talk
to you here we look forward to your
feedback tell us what you like and why
we don't like problems
you have etc thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]